SUPPORTERS WILL WRITE YOU OFF AS
NEW YORK IS MONICA CROWLEY,
SHE'S THE SENIOR FELLOW AT THE
LONDON CENTER AND HERE IN
WASHINGTON JAMAR JACOBY, AND
COREY LEWANDOWSKI COAUTHOR OF
RADIO LISTENERS, REALLY WORRIED,
I WANT TO HOLD OUT HOPE AND
RESERVE JUDGMENT FOR THE FINAL
DEAL.
YOU HEARD THE QUOTES FROM THE
PRESIDENT AT THAT MEETING.
OF COURSE THROW IN THE REFERENCE
TO THE HARD RIGHT.
PEOPLE AREN'T TOO HAPPY.
IF YOU DON'T FULFILL THOSE
CAMPAIGN PROMISES, WHAT WE WILL
SEE IN NOVEMBER IS A RETALIATION
THE BIGGEST CAMPAIGN PROMISE
I WENT TO ALL OF THOSE RALLIES,
WE SAW THAT MEXICO WAS GOING TO
PAY FOR IT.
THIS IS A HALLMARK OF THE
AMERICA FIRST.
THAT HAS BEEN HIS AGENDA, THAT'S
WHAT HE HAS CAMPAIGNED ON.
>> Laura: PEOPLE LIKE JEFF
CLOSER TO YOU ON IMMIGRATION, HE
SAID THAT THE WALL WILL BE
SOMETHING LIKE 700 MILES BUT IT
WOULD THAT BE ACCEPTABLE TO
TAKES TO SECURE THE BORDER AND
THE JEFF FLAKE IS NOT THE ONLY
PERSON IN CONGRESS WHO IS
WORKING ON THIS.
HE'S NOT THE ONLY PERSON WHO
SAID THAT PRESIDENT IS GOING IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
SO IS JOHN CORNYN.
PEOPLE IN THE HOUSE LIKE GOODLAD
AND LABRADOR.
THERE ARE PLENTY OF HARD LINED
REPUBLICANS WHO THINK WE NEED
RIGHT, THERE IS NOT VOTES TO DO
THAT.
>> IF YOU WANT TO FIND THE MONEY
THOUGHT A FORTIFIED BORDER WAS
IMPORTANT.
, WE NEED ROADS THERE, WE NEED A
WALL.
>> WE NEED MORE MEN, WE NEED
JUDGES, WE DID ALL KINDS OF
THINGS.
>> Laura: THAT IS AN ABSOLUTE
WHAT DOES IT HAVE TO DO?
>> BEFORE HE WAS INOCULATED HE
SAID WE SHOULD DO SOMETHING FOR
THE DACA KIDS?
WHY NOT HAVE SOME DEMOCRAT VOTES
WHY NOT HAVE SOME DEMOCRAT VOTE
VOTES?
>> Laura: YOUR FOR ENFORCEMENT
ENFORCEMENT.
>> Laura: CHUCK SCHUMER HAS
SAID HE IS FOR ENFORCEMENT.
>> BUT THEY ALSO WANT TO DO
SOMETHING FOR THE DACA KIDS.
>> Laura: I WANT TO BELIEVE IN
MY HEART OF HEARTS THERE IS NOT
SOME MAJOR SELLOUT IN THE
OFFING.
THAT WOULD BE THE END OF HIS
PRESIDENCY.
YOU ALREADY HAVE PEOPLE WHO ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THIS.
FEW PEOPLE HAVE GIVEN HIM BETTER
ADVICE THAN COREY SITTING HERE,
MYSELF, AND A FEW OTHERS.
HE HAS A LOT OF NEW FOUND
FRIENDS WHO ARE CALLING HIM
RACIST, SEXIST, XENA PHOBIC
YESTERDAY.
MEETING.
ESTABLISHMENT REPUBLICANS AND
OTHERS WHO HAVE LED US DOWN OVER
MANY DECADES, PEOPLE ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE AISLE.
I THINK WHAT YOU SAW IN THAT
MEETING, DONALD TRUMP KNEW WHAT
HE WAS DOING.
OF ALL OF HIS CAMPAIGN PROMISES,
BUILD THE WALL INSPIRED THE MOST
US DOWN ON THAT.
HIS PLATFORM ON DEALING WITH
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION ONCE AND FOR
ALL, HE KNOWS HE'S GOT ONE SHOT
BEFORE THE END OF THE YEAR IN
THE 2018 MIDTERM ELECTIONS.
BUILDING THE WALL, HE HAS TO END
AT SANCTUARY CITIES, HE HAS TO
END THE VISA LOTTERY PROGRAM,
HE'S GOT TO ACCELERATE
DEPORTATIONS AND HE'S GOT TO
UNBLOCK THOSE IMMIGRATION COURTS
UNBLOCK THOSE IMMIGRATION COURT
COURTS.
I KNOW THAT'S A TALL ORDER BUT
THAT'S WHAT HE PROMISED.
FEINSTEIN AND CORY GARDNER --
>> PEOPLE DON'T WANT TO MISS
WHAT I'M ABOUT TO REVEAL TO CORY
GARDNER.
LET'S WATCH.
>> THOSE FOLKS DON'T HAVE TO
IF PS TO WORK TO FIX PROBLEMS TO
FIX IMMIGRATION.
HIS JOB IS NOT TO SELL BOOKS,
HIS JOB IS NOT TO CARRY A TV
>> Laura: WE DIDN'T REALIZE
THAT HE IS ACTUALLY THE
PRESIDENT.
>> THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN
>> Laura: THEY CREATED IT BY
LEAVING THE BORDER OPEN!
>> DONALD TRUMP HAS PASSED THE
MASSIVE TAX REFORM PACKAGE AND
WHAT THE PRESIDENT IS GOING TO
DO IS FULFILL THE CAMPAIGN
PROMISES THAT HE OUTLINED.
WHAT WE SAW YESTERDAY WAS
HAVE THEM ACCOUNTABLE ON
TELEVISION, THE DEMOCRATS HATE
PROPAGANDA.
>> Laura: FOR LINDSEY GRAHAM
TO BE SITTING AT THE TABLE, YOUR
FRIEND STICK UP TO YOUR FRIENDS.
I LIKE HIM, VERY MUCH ALWAYS
HAVE.
FOX NEWS AND HARD RIGHT, HE
TRIED THIS LINE IN 2007.
WASHINGTON?
JOHN BOEHNER AND ERIC CANTOR.
THEY SOLD THE COUNTRY OUT
PRIMARILY ON IMMIGRATION.
ON THE ISSUE OF CHAIN MIGRATION,
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE SAID THEY ARE
NOT FOR REDUCTION TO CHAIN
MIGRATION.
>> OVER TIME WE DEFINITELY NEED
TO REBALANCE.
TOO MUCH FAMILY MIGRATION NOT
ENOUGH EMPLOYMENT BASED.
THAT IS A HISTORIC CHANGE, WERE
GOING TO CHANGE 200 YEARS OF
HISTORY.
DEMOCRATS AREN'T GOING TO BE
READY TO DO IT RIGHT NOW ACROSS
THE BOARD.
I THINK IT'S POSSIBLE TO MAKE
SOME CHANGES TO CHANGE
MIGRATION, TO TOTALLY CHANGE THE
SYSTEM I DON'T THINK IT'S GOING
TO HAPPEN.
>> Laura: WE CHANGED OUR
BROUGHT THEY KNEW AND THEIR
RELATIVES.
>> Laura: THERE ARE A MILLION
GREEN CARD GRANTS EVERY YEAR.
44% OUR FAMILY MIGRATION.
THERE ARE OTHER FAMILY
RECIPIENTS THAT COME IN --
>> THE FAMILIES WORK TOO.
99.9% OF THE FAMILIES WORK.
REPUBLICANS BELIEVE IN FAMILIES.
FAMILIES ARE THE SOCIAL FABRIC?
NOT FAMILY?
>> Laura: THERE BETTER THAN WE
ARE?
THE ILLEGALS COMING IN WITH ALL
THE EXTENDED FAMILY ARE BETTER
THAN THE AMERICAN WORKERS.
FAMILY MIGRATION IS NOT A BAD
CHILDREN.
ILLEGAL PEOPLE DONALD TRUMP SAID
COUNTLESS TIMES ON THE CAMPAIGN
TRAIL NEED TO GO HOME AND APPLY